let's go to our next caller why don't we
go to the six one three area code caller
from six one three please identify
yourself and what's on your mind today
um it is with me and that's you the
caller from six one three yes it is okay
so I was calling in to ask about how he
would feel that you can properly it is
another foreign policy question how you
feel that we can properly you know kind
of pressure American politicians to be
more anti drone because even like the
furthest left senators are still kind of
Pro drone like even Bernie Sanders said
here in an interval with Los Angeles
Times that drones have done some good
things and I'm like I just I don't
really see that when you know you have
six thousand people who died this year
from drone strikes alone and only like
five countries around the world like
terrorism worldwide kills what some like
thirty five thousand people every year
mostly in you know countries that have
Isis presence but you know American
terrorism radical American terrorism is
a really serious threat to these people
and is really turning a lot of people
against the United States so my question
is how can we get more left-wing energy
on this issue the reason why it's
difficult to reasons that it's difficult
number one is that by and large the
Democratic Party is pretty centrist and
so given the option of armed conflict on
the ground in some of these theaters and
drones even relatively left elected
officials are going to say you know I'd
kind of rather the drones and that
relates to another issue which is if we
didn't have and I'm trying to be as
pragmatic and straight up here as
possible
you know didn't have the drones some of
these situations would be boots on the
ground right and it wouldn't be big
boots on the ground it might be special
operations it might be SEAL Teams it
could be small operations but it would
still be troops on the ground they would
say that Americans will die they would
say Americans would die or or or might
die now you could make the case it would
be bad
if we didn't have the drones and needed
to put people on the ground because then
we would feel the costs of it more
directly now it doesn't mean you pointed
out that people are being turned against
us because of the use of drones around
the world that's a cost to the United
States but it's a different cost than
losing a member of the military on an
operation you have otherwise been done
with a drone so it's a very difficult
thing and I actually don't have an
answer for you because even for
left-wing politicians they see that a
lot of these missions that drones are
being sent out on our missions that are
going to happen no matter what no matter
what they say so they try to basically
cut losses and say we're better off with
the drone than with like a SEAL team or
commandos or something like that so I
don't have an answer I don't know how we
can get policy to become more anti drone
yeah I appreciate the pragmatism of your
response here because it is very hard so
to people to say ok if you want to be
involved in these conflicts
you know first say humanitarian reasons
or whatever else reasons for some reason
people support being in Afghanistan and
Iraq you know ok well it's going to be
you know your children that are on the
line people like know what no I don't
support that so they instead go for an
option that puts the children of the
people they say they're defending on the
line right absolutely no no in fact we
know that it's sometimes it's been
farmers who are just doing night farming
which is a common thing in certain parts
of the world we know it's gone wrong in
in so many different ways it's a tough
one and I wish I had more of an answer
for you mm-hmm I mean I honestly doesn't
seem like there is any answer and it's
and to me it seems like because of how
hard it is to intervene and in a way
that is humanitarian it might just not
be worth doing at all that's a sad you a
possible reality and it's pretty pretty
depressing but I appreciate you bringing
up this important issue to me really
really appreciate the call and on that
note we will go to a break thanks to
everybody who called in today we will
take calls again that I promise you